من وسط هذا الكوخ ساهم الشاب نايف المتحمي
في تشريع السياحه الريفيه في قريته بمركز
طاباب شمال مدينه ابها من خلال انشاء كوخ
خشبي اطلق عليه كوخ نسبه لمحبته لهذه
الشجره
[موسيقى]
في البدايه ودي تخبرنا كيف فكره الكوخ
الجميله
من خمس سنوات طبقت كوخ عندي في البيت
فلما شفت الكوخ يعني مره جميل وصار عندي
يعني ناس متابعين لي في شغله هذه
سافرت دوله اوروبيه
وشفت لكم هذا شفت التصميمه يعني مره جميل
وملفت
الكوخ الصاروه
خمسه انواع من الشجر
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا نايف
تصميم الكوخ هذا ما هو المزار سياحي فكره
انه يكون
الكوخ هذا الساحجي ويقضي يوم ريفي جميل في
هذا المكان الرائع
الكوخ الان تحت الانشاء متى ممكن يا نايف
يكون جاهز ويقصدون السياح الكوخ صار لي
سنه ونص اشتغل عليه وان شاء الله خلال
الصيف 20 23 يكون جاهز
[موسيقى]
يتكون الكوخ من عده غرف ولكن الذي شد
انتباهي هذا المشب الذي ماخوذ من الطابع
العسيري ثم تشاهدون هذا الحجر موجود في
اغلب البيوت الاثريه
مدينه ابها محمد خالد العربي